So now that we can sign
the user in all the way
to the Games service, let's
sign them out as well.
Now for the purpose of this
tutorial and to help debugging,
I'm going to put this as a
button on the front page.
Realistically, I don't
think you'd want to do this.
Sign-out, you'd
probably want to keep
more hidden in a menu
option somewhere.
My hunch is it's going
to be fairly uncommon
for an actual user to want
to sign out from Play Games
once they've signed in.
No one's going to
say, I'd really
like to stop earning
achievement progress now.
However, it does
make your life easier
for testing against both sort
of the signed-in and signed-out
state.
So let's do that.
I'm going to switch over to
my  And quite possibly,
for the reasons I just stated,
there is no official artwork
for Google+ sign-out button.
However, I did include
some with the artwork ZIP
file that we're going use.
So first things first, I'm going
to add a button onto the screen
here.
This is going to be a
custom button with no text.
And I have a-- notice we have
a whole lot more images now.
That's thanks to the
Play Games services
bundle that we've
added to our project,
and here's our sign-out.
And we're just going to keep
this for all of our states.
All right.
Next, let's open up
our assistant editor,
and I'm going to Control-drag
to add an ID outlet-- sorry,
IB outlet, and we're going
to call this signOutButton.
And then, let's say
underneath my sign-in button
was pressed method, I
will add a sign-out button
was pressed method.
Now, let's fill this out.
You might think, gosh, since we
signed in through GPP sign-in,
we could sign out
through GPP sign-in.
And indeed, there is
a sign-out method.
However, we're not
going to do that here.
And that's because
there is no equivalent
finish with auth
handler for signing out.
And you'll end up
in this weird state
where you'll have signed out
from your GPP sign-in object,
but your GPG manager, the
Google Play Games manager,
has no idea that you signed out.
It still might try to
access the cache data
and might try to submit
scores and achievements
without realizing, until
later, that something is wrong.
So we're not going to do this.
And instead, we're
going to call GPGManager
sharedInstance signout.
And this method will
do a number of things.
One, the GPG manager will talk
to GPP sign-in shared instance
and call sign-out on that.
In addition, it will clear
out any cache data that
gets stored on
behalf of the user
and perform some
additional cleanup tasks.
So this is really the
right way to sign out.
We can try this and
see what happens.
Whoops, looks like
my sign-in button
is offscreen or my sign-off
button is offscreen--
and that's because I
forgot to go back in here
and adjust my auto sizing to
make sure that it is anchored
to the bottom
instead of the top.
Sorry about that.
And yes, I suppose
I should really
be starting to use auto
layout and constraints here.
I just haven't gotten
used to it yet.
Anyway, with that out of
the way, let's run it.
There we go.
There's our buttons.
So I'm already signed in,
as you can see in our NSLog,
and now I'm going to sign out.
And actually, nothing happens.
But I am actually signed out
because if I sign in again,
it will take me back to the
OAuth 2.0 permissions screen.
Because I have signed
out, the service
says, OK, if you want
to sign in again,
we are going to double check
and confirm rather than sign you
in silently, which is
the right behavior.
So I'm going to go
back and click Accept.
I'm going to go back in, and it
looks like I'm signed in again.
So this is nice.
However, your
typical user is not
going to be able to look
at their console log
to figure out whether they're
signed in or signed out.
So let's add one more
refinement, which
is hiding or showing the
appropriate buttons based
on your signed-in status.
So I'm going to
stop this, and we're
going to go into my intro
view controller dot m file,
and let's create
another method-- I'm
going to put it up here-- called
refreshInterfaceBasedOnSignin,
because I like
long method names.
The first question we
need to ask ourselves
is, how do we know if the
user is signed in or not?
One way, I suppose, to do it
would be to set up an instance
variable, and perhaps, it
might finish with auth handler.
I could set this to true or yes.
And then the sign-out,
I could set it to no.
Turns out we can also
get this information
by asking the GPG manager.
And the way you do this is we
create a little BOOL, signedIn
equals GPGManager
sharedInstance hasAuthorizer.
And this is essentially a way of
asking, is the user signed it?
The engineer who has
written this method
would like me to let you know
that technically, it's really
a method that determines
whether the library sees
an auth object associated
with this user.
It doesn't actually confirm
that this auth object is valid
or not.
But for all intents
and purposes,
this is a good way to find
out if the user is signed in.
And then, we can simply hide
or show buttons based on this.
So we're going to call our
self that sign-in button.
We'll hide this, if
user is signed in.
And our sign-out button, we
will set to not user signed in.
In addition, let's
change that label
where we tell the
user to sign in.
Probably don't need to tell
them that if they're already
signed in.
So if signed in,
self.signinlabel.txt
equals Welcome, player!
Otherwise, and this is
where you can tell them
sign in for achievements
and leaderboards.
All right.
Now, we just have
to call this method
at the appropriate moments.
Turns out there are
three places where
we want to call this method.
The first would be to finish
with auth, after we've
called sign in to
Google Play Games.
It would also be
appropriate to put this
at the end of our sign-in
to Google Play Games
method, either one works.
Next, we're going to want to
do it on sign out was pressed.
Remember that
signing out does not
hit our finish with
auth error handler,
so we'll also want to
make sure we call it here.
And then finally, we do want
to call it in view will appear.
This last call is nice to
have in something like this,
where you've got your views
inside a navigation controller,
and maybe you're
switching back and forth
between different views.
When this view is
ready to come up again,
it's good to make sure that
all the interface elements are
as they should be based
on user's sign-in status.
So let's try this now.
And this time, we have a little
"Welcome, player!" message.
The sign-in button is hidden,
and the sign-out button
is the only one
that's available.
If I click Sign Out,
nearly immediately,
the sign-out button goes away,
the sign-in button is back.
I get back the prompt
again to sign in
for leaderboards
and achievements.
I'm going to say, yes, I'm
going to accept, and we're back.
So now that this is done, I can
go back into my [? NIB ?] file,
and I'm going to move
my sign-out button
right on top of my sign-in
button, since only one of them
will ever be
visible at any time.
So there you go.
We're now properly changing the
look of the interface depending
on whether or not the user
has signed into Play Games.
So this is great.
There are a couple
of more refinements
I would like to make,
and we'll handle
those in the next lesson.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]